this is one of your favorite hours
America it's a millionaire themed hour
we are going to take calls from the
mythical creature known as the
millionaire today and calls from
millionaires only because we want to
learn on your behalf and let you learn
as you listen what they've done how
they've lived how do you become one what
are the habits of a millionaire because
hey the theory is if you were to do the
habits of a millionaire then you would
become millionaire if you do the habits
of poor people money habits of poor
people then you would be poor people
right and pretty simple stuff so we're
going to call it we're going to follow
that you know and so if I want to get
skinnier what do I do I talk to skinny
people right that's what I want to do
that's how I do it I want to learn how
they did that if I want to be married a
long time I don't talk to somebody been
married 20 minutes Allen talks might
been married 64 years how'd you do that
in business we call that best practices
you find a successful business and you
emulate the practices of that business
in wealth building we call it best
practices you find someone successful at
building wealth and you emulate you copy
what they've been doing in their lives
and also in the process of doing this we
get to put to bed go ahead and just you
know dispute with actual facts some of
the mythology going around in the
political world out there that
millionaires have all inherited their
wealth millionaires are all crooks
millionaires are all famous entertainers
or athletes millionaires are all
brilliant they have GPI GPAs they all
have 4.2 I'm not a rocket scientist Dave
well turns out that those are all myths
and you'll see it as we talk to folks
today a million dollar net worth is what
a millionaire is it's not someone that
makes a million dollars a year contrary
to what some idiot politicians say they
don't know the definition of the word
the word means a million dollar net
worth your net worth is calculated by
what you own minus what you owe your
assets minus your liabilities equals a
million dollars then you are a
millionaire so if you have a 1 million
dollar home and it is paid for you are
by definition a millionaire but just
like that something you don't have a
bunch of other debts right
but what you own minus what you owe it
is not your income that is a net worth
calculation and that determines that
you're a millionaire and so that's what
we're going to do and by looking at
someone's net worth and what it's
composed of we can kind of tell how they
got to this point of winning with money
there's approximately ten million
millionaires in America today 88% of
them that's nine out of ten or
first-generation rich started with
nothing and they left the cave killed
something and drugged at home so let's
talk to a couple of them we're going to
start with Matt in South Bend Indiana
Matt welcome to the show David be
talking with you you too man so what is
your net worth sir yeah well it has 1.6
million ok cool and what is that
invested in it's invested in stocks and
bonds and some cash about how about how
much 65 percent in some say is in the
stocks and about 35 in bonds and 5% cash
of the 1.6 yes you don't have any real
estate well just the house we have which
it's a house is valued at two hundred
thousand and uh we have about seventy
thousand equity on that okay so it's not
paid a little bit a little bit in real
estate okay all right so the house is
not paid for no it's not okay yo 130 on
it alright and and then the rest so the
rest of it is all in stocks and bonds
and cash got it okay and what is your
what how old are you
58 okay cool how much of this did you
inherit really very little my father
passed in October and we got about
$30,000 us for me and that's enough for
my brother okay so obviously this wealth
did not come from him what's been your
income over your working lifetime but
how is a level you know entry level 35
years ago and yeah $13,000 or excuse me
16,000 and then made a much as I hurt
20,000 okay all right so you've averaged
if we
guests would say your average around
about 75 or 80 thousand 75 to 80 all
right cool
and what's your career field perfumers
management and manufacturing our company
gotcha
okay do you have a degree I do have a
bachelor's degree in chemistry and a NBA
okay all right and what was your GPA on
your bachelor's about two six okay all
right good I love it that's perfect so
where did this money come from I mean
how did you get to that making 75 or 80
a year
I have the good fortune to listen to
someone when I was very early at the
company I was working with and they said
anyhow if I you know you don't need a
don't need to be buying a lot of
different things you need to save your
money for retirement so I listened to
him and and we just saved a really from
the very beginning slow and steady in a
401k type plan okay so your 401k is
giving you great returns over these
years because obviously making that kind
of money add it all up hardly equals 1.6
so the growth on your accountant must
have been really good it's been invested
in fully invest in mutual funds and and
a little bit in bonds but mostly in
equities okay all right very cool it
sounds funny you're fortunate that the
company also had a pension that it was
frozen some years ago oh so I did have
better both of pensions for a while as
well as a 401k
okay did you it doesn't sound like it
but you didn't use any debt to grow this
wealth
you didn't vest using borrowed money
right no okay never did alright and what
part has giving played in your financial
plan it's been important to us we've
been consistent givers to our church as
well as a to organizations such as the
United Way and all and uh over the last
couple years we've kind of recognized
we've been very fortunate and been able
to to give more randomly with but with a
purpose
sure I'm sure targeted what's most
expensive pair jeans you ever bought I
was last week they were $42.90 whoa only
three miles
busting out here man so uh and before
you were a millionaire how many
brand-new cars did you buy we've had
four cars and and new cars and uh and
our marriage Alliance in the last one
was in 87 oh you bought a car back in 87
new yeah we still don't have that one we
have others but I love it they've all
been used cool cool
so if you were talking to the 25 year
old version of you that's listening
right now what would you tell them
because you're a millionaire and they
want to know what to do I tell them to
to start early and stay consistent stay
with it I also tell them that that
emergency fund is really crucial for
your peace of mind it's incredible the
list that you get when you realize you
have that cushion and so don't overlook
that in your plan and I think about
starting early what it does is it gives
you options later in life you know when
you're 55 or whatever yeah and and if
you don't mind that it really was an
important part for my wife and I the
options piece was a year ago in January
I died Omaha playing basketball and at
sudden cardiac arrest Wow Wow now that
that makes a difference ever that margin
Matt thank you for sharing your great
American hero brother I love it it's a
millionaire theme our on the Dave Ramsey
show hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show so you have to break the cycle
you have to flip this thing on its head
and make it behave you've got to get so
fired up and wired up that you're broke
friends think you've lost your mind
you